[Music]
Disney Zootopia stole the hearts of fans
everywhere but there are tons of things
you've probably never noticed stay tuned
to find out the funniest thing you
probably missed in the movie if you're a
Disney fanatic be sure to subscribe for
more awesome videos now let's get to the
10 things you probably never knew about
Zootopia Museum
welcome to Zootopia very details there
are a ton of animals in Zootopia of
course and they all have some furry
appearances but did you know that
Disney's animators took a lot of care to
make sure the fur was realistic instead
of just slapping generic fur on all of
the animals the animators did a ton of
research all of the animals fur is based
on real life for instance the polar
bears don't have white Verve they have
clear fur that appears white just like
in real life foxes have fur that start
out dark at the roots and gets lighter
towards the tip they included all sorts
of details like that the animals were
also made more realistic by having stuff
in their fur like leaves and sticks real
animals aren't always all that clean so
it makes sense that the Zootopia animals
wouldn't be either you can really see
the debris in yaks the yaks firm you
know I'm gonna hit the pause button
right there cuz we're all good on bunny
Scout cookies the animators also used
some advanced animation technology for
the fur in other movies they would
digitally plug first strand by strand
that they needed to move but in Zootopia
they were able to use a new technology
to trim hair that appeared beneath the
clothes pretty cool a Star Wars
reference Disney is the best of throwing
in all sorts of fun Easter eggs in all
their movies and Zootopia is no
different there are so many Disney
references in this film that it's hard
to keep up with all of them ever since
Disney bought the Star Wars franchise
they have started throwing in some
space-age references they went way back
to the original Star Wars films for the
reference when Judy is trying to get the
train car started
she powers it up only to have it quit
working on her then she whacks it and it
roars back to life
hallelujah this is just like what Han
Solo did in the Millennium Falcon in
Empire Strikes Back
talk about a throwback what other Easter
eggs are hidden in the movie to baby
elephants are dressed like Anna and Elsa
from frozen and we even see a stuffed
Mickey Mouse in a stroller during one of
Nick's schemes one of the directors rich
Moore says there are all sorts of film
references throughout Zootopia he says
they had lots of time to include little
things because they spent two years
working on the movie
it definitely has paid off what other
Easter eggs have you noticed it really
is a zoo Zootopia follows the rabbit
Judy Hopps she becomes the first ever
rabbit to join the police force
rabbits are typically seen as really
timid and not cut out for police work
but judy is no ordinary rabbit it's
called a hustle sweetheart she and
criminal fox Nick Wilde team up to solve
a case Zootopia really is a perfect
animal world all of the animals in the
world lived together mostly in peace
Judy and Nick discover that someone is
poisoning predators and making them act
like they would in the wild but they
totally defeat the bad guys in order to
make a whole world full of animals the
animators had to include a whole bunch
of species there are 64 different
species of animals in Zootopia that's
crazy the only place you can see that
many animals isn't an actual zoo of
course there are rabbits and foxes there
is a tiger and a rhino on the police
force the assistant mayor is a sheep but
most of the species are just background
characters it's really amazing how much
detail went into creating this world
full of animals and every animal has
been totally anthropomorphize that's the
big fancy word for acting human-like
they typically walk on two feet and do
all sorts of human things like drink
coffee and read newspapers Judy's outfit
when Judy joins the police force her
boss doesn't have a lot of faith in her
abilities to go after bad guys he puts
her on parking ticket duty which she is
not too happy about sir I don't want to
be a meter maid I want to be a real cop
but did you notice that Judy is wearing
body armor she's wearing a bulletproof
vest on the outside of her uniform at
that vests would probably be a little
longer to actually prevent any damage to
her little rabbit organs this isn't that
weird considering Judy as a cop for what
is weird is that she is the only
Zootopia cop to wear body armor she's
also wearing protective armbands and
kneepads but no other cough is Zootopia
is generally considered to be safe and
even in the real human world
cops don't usually put external body
armor on unless they're in an extra
dangerous situation so why does Judy
wear so much armor is it because she
knows she's going to end up
investigating a super dangerous case
maybe the armor makes Judy feel less
insecure about being a small prey animal
on the police force whatever the reason
the look is totally unique to officer
Hopps why do you think she wears all the
body armor duke weaselton duke weaselton
is one of the bad guys in the movie he
is of course a weasel and he's mostly
involved in crimes like selling bootleg
DVDs and pickpocketing ioke weaselton
and I ain't talking rabbit and ain't
nothing you can do to me but he is
tasked with stealing the flower that has
the toxin in it but this whole character
is a giant easter egg he's named of the
duke of weaseltown one of the villains
from frozen
just like weaselton the duke of
weaseltown is really greedy he is only
after well he also is the one who
declares Elsa a threat to their lives
and orders her to be sentenced to
capital punishment he tries to make
amends at the end but Elsa is no fool
she Deportes him from the kingdom duke
weaselton and the duke of weaseltown are
also voiced by the same actor Alan Tudyk
plays both of these villains tudyk is
most famous for his role as wash the
goofy pilot from the hit sci-fi show
Firefly he later starred on the sitcom
Suburgatory Sudak voiced another disney
villain he played Alastair krei in Vic
hero 6 back in 2014
then he voiced droid k2s Oh in Star Wars
rogue one Alan Tudyk is definitely no
stranger to Disney voice acting he plays
a great villain and he also plays a
great rooster in moaña
that's right he is the talent behind hey
hey the dvds speaking of the duke of
bootleg the
DVDs that are sold right duke weaselton
are hilarious and are totally Disney
Easter eggs there are all titles of
Disney movies that were already released
or were in the works when Zootopia was
released but the creators made the
titles more adapted to a world full of
animals ah well hello step right up
anything you need I got it we love big
hero six instead of big hero 6
there's floats in instead of frozen the
cover of wrinkled is hilarious it's a
horse dressed like Rapunzel from tangled
the horse has the same long blonde hair
how funny
instead of wreck-it Ralph there is reka
try no that's the perfect animal to play
Ralph don't you think
even though Moana had not been released
we saw a DVD called Mia wanna we guess
that's about a Polynesian cat there was
also giraffe 'ok that was supposed to be
a nod to gigantic a movie about the
fairy tale Jack in the Beanstalk but
Disney cancelled the movie back in 2017
we think that these film titles are so
creative they are funny jokes for the
animal world heads they are also Easter
eggs the creators of utopia
really put in so many awesome details
think those are funny references wait
till you see some other Disney stir eggs
all about bellwether the assistant mayor
of Zootopia is a little lamb named
bellwether at the beginning of the movie
she comes across as really timid she's
always being overworked and overlooked
by her boss mayor Lionheart bellwether
is not such a sweet sheep however after
years of being mistreated by predators
she believes prey are superior predators
they may be strong and loud but prey
outnumber predators 10:00 to 1:00
she is revealed to be the main
antagonist she orders predator species
to be rounded up and given the toxin
that makes them savage and feral in
hopes that she can convince the world
creditors are evil but she is stopped by
Judy and Nick she may be evil but her
character has some interesting animation
facts to make her seem sweet and
innocent animators based her look after
some classic Disney lambs make mine
music and melody time for Disney movies
from the 1940s she is designed after the
Lambs from
to movies also the animators put a lot
of work into her wardrobe she has six
different outfits one is a dress with
scissors on it since sheep gets sheared
all of her clothes are supposed to be
wool
I guess FINA sheep didn't give her
enough wool bellwether definitely pulled
the wool over our eyes you could say
she's like a wolf in sheep's clothing
okay dumb joke we'll see ourselves out
whoo place judy judy is such a lovable
character from the very beginning we
fall in love with her because she is so
optimistic she has overcome a major
obstacle and becoming the first bunny on
the police force and she is really
dedicated to making the world a better
place it was important that Disney got
the perfect actress to voice judy hopps
and they totally did she's played by
Jennifer Goodwin Jennifer is a real-life
Disney Princess at least she has played
one for several years
you probably recognize Jennifer from
Once Upon a Time
she has played Mary Margaret aka Snow
White
since 2011 the show just ended in 2018
if you think about it Snow White and
Judy have a lot in common they are both
always positive and fiercely independent
and they are both dedicated to doing
good Jennifer Goodwin married Prince
Charming that's right
she fell in love with her on-screen
husband from Once Upon a Time
she and Josh Dallas have been married
since 2014 see she really is a disney
princess she apparently always wanted to
be one we're so glad she got her wish we
wonder if she always wanted to be a
crime-fighting bunny too cheetah danger
a lot of work went into making
zootopia's cast as realistic as talking
animals can be that included a trip to
Africa filmmakers went to study some
animals in real life the director of
cinematography Nathan Warner had a
pretty scary experience with a cheetah
while he was there he met a rescued
cheetah but the cheetah was not a fan of
the camera Warner was using he left up
on him oMG we would have been absolutely
terrified that is scary AAF thankfully
neither the cheetah nor the director
were harmed still we're glad that didn't
happen
speaking of cheetahs officer clawhauser
is one of our favorite characters
goodness they really did hire bunny he's
just so sweet he's kind of chubby bird
cheetah but otherwise he's a pretty
realistic looking cat he even has the
dark markings that look like tears on
cheetahs they also threw in a Disney
Easter egg on him one of the spots on
his chief looks like Mickey Mouse's head
we wonder if the directors decided to
make officer clawhauser the opposite of
scary since they had such a scary
encounter with a real-life cheetah it's
pretty funny to think about how
different the character is from the
fierce African Cats Judy's playlist
we've seen a lot of Disney's drags in
Zootopia but this last one might be the
most creative one when Judy is on the
train through Zootopia she turned on her
mp3 player she picked some upbeat tunes
to set her mood before she starts her
new career as a police officer she
chooses a song called try everything by
gazelle and the song is inspiring AF
seriously it makes us feel just like
Judy like we can overcome any challenge
but did you ever take a good look at her
playlist it's hilarious after try
everything the next song is let it go
this is supposed to be a parody of
binits song from frozen although we
wonder what letting it go to really
means underneath that you see another
Disney parody song part of your rule
it's based on the Little Mermaid song
part of your world isn't about Hermer
sheep then we've got a hit song from an
alternative Lion King we bet can you
feel the fluff tonight is a super
romantic song in Zootopia finally we see
array bunny Knights instead of Arabian
Nights we've a totally be bound to see
an all rabbit version of Aladdin which
of these fake Disney songs would you
want to listen to let us know in the
comments and that's it for the 10 things
in Zootopia you probably never knew
check out our community page on YouTube
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]